so i still don't need a gun
i only want a gun because episode 103
still don't need a gun
[Music]
we have a backdrop
we haven't tabled the shape of a table
that's this is the right shape for this
it is but this is a trapezoid correct
yeah i don't know
um
to do it over again i don't know if i
get this table
i think i get the same the thing about
this table that no one would guess
very heavy
like this dumb red top that could be
plywood is like
made of lead okay um
bianca hi hi i think guys bianca's
can you feel the energy she's got
she remembered to remember i remember
what her week was like
i remembered and i reiterated to myself
before you came down from your room
and so i was like i'm not going to blink
the sad part is it's so lackluster
uh so i just i visited my friend who had
a baby
and i visited the baby
and i believe i saw a picture of it
i didn't post anything but that's okay
you posted a picture of you and a baby
on instagram it was a different baby
okay so
oh
for even [ __ ] suggesting it i could
not have been more wrong
i think that the baby i saw you with was
the baby you visited bianca i'm
baby visited me
which i forgot about
that's the photo you saw then i visited
a baby
and then i went to park and it was my
friend's birthday we played
giant jenga and we drank
drinks and we in a park i also saw a
picture of you at the beach
that was the baby that came to me that
was the first baby that you were talking
about great the second baby was in the
valley and the third
hang was at a park
nobody buy a park
covered just because you're you guys are
in high school i know and you have to
drink some places everything nowadays
you can't get caught everything with
coveted smoke of cigarettes
it's like getting light-headed have you
been on uh getting fingered okay have
you been on covered dates and it's like
would you like to take a walk yeah but i
think it's funny
like look lady
here are the options
we can either take a walk or we can go
to my house
right one's gonna you're gonna feel it
and just pick your poison right it's
true so the one i feel like now in covet
or post covert or whatever we are
wherever we are we'll never really be
gone i don't think i mean we'll talk
about it yeah but um
everything's a bit more wholesome
you know yeah i like it i like it too so
yeah park hangs
everything's great you're not forced
well i guess you could technically have
been forced to sleep with people
prematurely because of the not me you
might come to a house thing
no not you though it's not my favorite
you have it
it's not within your it's not who you
are it's not how you run it i don't get
i i i don't
i've you don't say that
and a freak
i am a british freak yes you're
i'm gonna go ahead and you're a um
fruit
i don't like you're a bad
you're a freak
yeah free okay you're a preacher
free free
um
free
okay so i did okay i'm actually proud of
myself with that recap great great recap
thank you good job
um what have you been doing with your
thoughts
on a
documentary thing yeah
my friend of course cat the famous cat
from the podcast um
and
uh
it's the hardest thing i've ever done
we went to joshua tree to
uh just work out there just did you just
accidentally talk ayahuasca well
it wasn't ayahuasca
sweetheart and what an accident i never
i don't like you know i don't love
nature i do enjoy the desert i do enjoy
this it's so weird that you like the
desert of all terrains i love the desert
first of all but i'm a lover of the
outsides yeah will you party in the park
so
yo come go college past 30.
[ __ ] you i'm 26.
i'm 19. i don't know what the [ __ ] is
popping i shouldn't even be here this is
not legal
uh i don't even have a podcasting
license
the he uh
did did uh ditch rooms
and one night how many enough to trip or
to just just drop no enough to trip
like uh it was a great it was tech
whatever i did one of the ones
no uh
there he sent me some chocolate ones too
um and uh
ayahuasca
has opened a new channel of
mushrooms
okay um and i'm going to be vague about
it and just say
it was [ __ ] wild
do you need to do ayahuasca anymore
could you just do the shrooms and chill
ayahuasca is that's my girl so
kid shows me your side chick
shrooms are the friend who reminds me
it's like when you're it's like uh
when a guy would go to war
the lady that was back home would visit
his hit one of his friends or family
maybe more like family uh so
shrooms are the family or ayahuasca's
cousin then i'm like we just get
together and me and shrimps get together
and talk about ayahuasca positively or
negatively positively i mean i live in a
different world you understand this
it's so wild
it's wild okay that's all i'll say it's
not like no no yeah but it's just wild
it was good yeah
it's just
involuntary just crazy [ __ ]
yeah like spirit padre
is almost too pedestrian a term for
wherever for where i am
they don't you can't it it's a musical
note you can't even say some words can't
even get to where i am you know what's
weird i do want to try shrooms again but
you know i have a weird eye condition i
never told you about called
visual snow
anyways it's basically i see like static
tell snow is the name of every
band
that sends a demo in
they never get signed
we are visual snow
welcome to our showcase
anyways i have it so apparently
psychedelics make it a little bit worse
but i didn't notice anything after
ayahuasca but i did notice it once after
shrimp so i'm like i kind of want to
maybe it's worth a little
visual so it's basically like you see
like i see static
all the time
how long when did that start
i don't know like 20 years ago oh so
when you were
at six
but you were uh you did were you scared
no it's like slowly it's not like a real
it's not like i woke up one day and i
was in like the 1950s and it's really
like put a jacket on and i was like
what's the matter like why it's snowing
it's such a small snowball fight anyone
and you're just collecting nothing
handfuls of nothing and throwing them in
people oh gotcha good people like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about lady
no it's at night i can notice it more
during the day it's not really visible
that would make me feel very sorry for
myself what
uh any sort of malady like that oh i
don't feel sorry for myself like ever
great so i have a thing that i wanted to
share with the good people the list
we'll call them the listeners maybe um
the uh
that there was a night where
this is like for anyone who feels sorry
for themselves or suicidal or whatever
um
depression suicide feeling sorry for
yourself
um
speaking of which i did a guy's podcast
probably two months ago was about mental
health
got a dm two weeks ago
killed himself jumping
jumped off the golden gate bridge that's
really literally jumped off like i
literally thought
i was like i thought you're gonna make a
joke like he's doing better no
no oh no yeah just like un
unbelievable so anyway this is the
thought i had uh
on plant medicine one time which is
if you're
[Music]
feeling sorry for yourself if you think
like this life sucks
everyone's got it better than me
the thought i had and i wasn't even
feeling especially sorry for myself it's
just more of a general thing
is all right there's eight billion
possibilities
on earth right eight billion different
lives
if you think you can beat yours
spin the wheel and try
well isn't spinning they're going to try
and killing yourself kind but it's not
what i'm saying is even not spinning the
wheel like even not killing yourself if
it's d my next thought was like oh i'm
not gonna beat this life
right or just go volunteer in [ __ ]
poverty yeah tell me if you're happy
like you know i don't know how do people
get appreciation and gratitude if
chemically it's really hard for them
just think about spinning the wheel okay
they literally think about spinning the
wheel like could i beat this life easily
how many lives are better than mine
versus how many lives are worse than
mine yeah in out of eight billion
it's a lot of people with worse lives if
you're listening to this just the fact
that you're listening to this is that
you
have
the enough money to buy the equipment to
hear about you right and the equipment's
like what do you mean a phone yeah yeah
the phones a lot of people don't have
them right so
like
you know
it's hard but appreciation's incredibly
hard to come by yeah i'm i'm the
opposite i never feel bad for myself i
always blame myself for any thing bad
that happens it's like let's find a way
well how this
the responsibilities on you i don't like
putting the responsibility on other
people yeah so when i feel bad for my
life i'm like it's gotta be pretty bad
but
i guess i never thought that feeling bad
for yourself was a part of depression
um
yeah
yeah you it's you really feel bad for
yourself and in like a pity way like
sometimes okay and like uh it's i suck
okay and then
kind of like
this sucks
everyone's having fun but me everyone's
a joyous everyone's having right
everyone's having fun it's just i'm not
what's wrong with me
and then you just pile on there
got it um
i also did comedy star comedy i did
indoors top tier comedy indoor [ __ ]
comedy
saturday night
comedy store
main room mine
um
was the table weird
yeah i don't know what it was for
there's a table
there's like a buffet table on the
on the stage
did i guess you're supposed to stay
behind no one knew though yeah that's so
funny well when they first explained to
us i thought that was gonna be sad and
like why is there a table on stage no
it's
to make sure
it keeps the comic at the required
distance for the city
so if you went further than that you
would technically be in splash i don't
want to say what i did
okay
no one knew i said what is this for and
no one said anything that's very so and
then i literally i'm
leslie followed me and she was like what
the [ __ ] is it no one told us
hey there's gonna be a tablespoon also
but it's more funny when you guys make
fun of something of course so no it's
the best thing that can happen is when i
make fun of something it's kind of the
it's i make the table's life the table
is never gonna forget it
tablespoon gonna be talking about the
night on stage at the comedy store for
the rest of its table live
um did you like it was it weird it was
so much easier is it better than the
yeah but aren't are they in their cars
are they sitting no they're sitting but
it's just
where would you rather give a speech in
a in a
with walls and a ceiling or just nothing
sirens
when cold it's like or 71
everyone's facing toward you no
distractions
mm-hmm
and you could the laughs wouldn't escape
a lot of times when i get laughed like
no there's the last will get in the wind
and i need them i need those laughs and
they get away
um
so
i tweeted a picture
do you see my anne frank instagram oh we
shouldn't get people yeah that's what
i'm saying people didn't like it i mean
people loved it except four people
complained and it's like well
and i just kept saying you didn't have a
problem with the slavery sketches that
are streaming on netflix right now
no
not a bit of problems
yep it was it was it was a twitter
karate
and my blood my heart rate my blood
pressure did not go up because i'm
i'm a at least a black belt in twitter
karate
so you're good like how many followers
lose none okay
lost none may
didn't gain but didn't lose me
may have gained 50. now that i think of
it so
guys if you want to get followers
either show your ass or
do
uh holocaust jokes
either
um whoa
it's groans feels gross um
now bine gave a speech
sure did and the firs the headline is it
doubled the oscars ratings which is like
jesus yeah
wow they really didn't want to they'd
rather watch an old man
talk
than watch
no no no no sexy people other way you
said it double the double the oscar
ratings they'd rather watch an old man
talk than watch cool people it got twice
what the oscars got
oh i thought you're saying it doubled
the oscars rating it did
okay i know we're saying this
it's just the grammar i thought you were
saying it made it boosted the oscars
reading time oh no
yeah i got it uh no no so many people
went so many people people were so much
more interested in
joe biden than
than um
nomad land you can believe it
i was thinking of
chris did a remote rocked at a remote
when he hosted the oscars where he went
to the magic johnson theater and asked
people what that i remember that was so
they were just like they were like what
but i was gonna when i was in the in
joshua tree i was gonna go to people in
rvs and be like are you excited about
nomad land
winning it's finally you get to speak
it's you
um by the way there's a whole not as
many controversy tell me that
that an asian uh chinese woman directed
the movie and it's like so wait she can
tell the story she could tell a story
about poor white people even though
she's a rich asian woman oh that's a new
one
but what's your what's the count what's
that encounter too uh that only certain
people can tell certain stories
well i mean that's not true because
think of all the things that we've
watched so far up until this point they
haven't all been told by like
mo it's mostly white men writing
like black gangster movies now now they
are no yeah no they are what i'm saying
is like now they are and but it's just
one of these like huh interesting
um
so anyway the i didn't i saw the clips
of biden's speech
yeah i'm not [ __ ] sorry i'm not
watching any
i don't know presidential speeches are
always so
boring
yeah and you'll get them you'll just get
the highlights yeah they they he did
have two first guy to ever do it with
two women behind him
oh which sounds sexist i know but it's
actually the opposite you did this and
it yeah i did that i did the i did the
horns
i did the q anon horns
yeah two women behind him speak of the
house vice president um
and that's never happened before and as
far as i'm gonna it better not happen
again
uh or where there's gonna be an
insurrection too what was funny is how
the gop takeaways were so they the gop
takeaways from his speech were
um just tr transport yourself back to a
bad relationship where you're talking
and the person like takes one thing is
like runs with it and you want to pull
your hair out like the no meat
thing was so weird i don't i i i think
that was before that i think it was
before the speech is when he addressed
congress yeah
um
and then they said that you couldn't
he's going to have an embargo on uh
hamburgers
which is so dumb
but they just go [ __ ] it let's see it's
like hamburger literally ready 21. yeah
it's just
so dumb but it is funny the
there's a big uh restaurant in new york
11 madison that's going no meat
and
there's a
art there's like a feature in the new
york times it's going no mate like the
culinary whatever like the main cooking
thing is going meat-free forever
yeah okay
yes it's real it's you're a climate
denier if you eat the meat
guys breathe i'm sorry but you're a
climate denier and you're gonna you're
gonna um
you're gonna and you've also depleted
the ocean
but
yes it's so good i
syndicated
that one
yes
so my point is with biden biden's doing
something that i
is kind of amazing biden is basically
trump was say
the little duval
of
social media
and biden is the frank ocean of social
media like doesn't talk about it
just does some [ __ ] quietly
and he's all the [ __ ] he's doing there's
not noisy
like that's not they they don't even
really debate it he's just going like i
want four trillion dollars
and then
i don't know and then it's not like a
big problem it's not it's just he's
doing [ __ ] he's doing a lot of [ __ ]
almost
it's not
secretly it's not executive orders
but
it's
he's so boring
they don't even cover the laws he makes
also
high approval rating yeah well because
it's people like when you give him money
it's a bit like uh
telling my mom
ayahuasca made me love her more okay but
it's hard to argue with that right and
also
54 53.4 approval rating that's pretty
good yeah it's probably at least eight
points higher than trump was just at his
highest i think no
uh yeah i don't know um but
yeah no it's very
people like boring politics now right
now we want boring politics and we want
a little bit of stability and it's
funny when people call joe biden you
know like he's
uh
half dead he doesn't know what's going
on he's true right all those things but
i'm like even a half dead [ __ ]
got us on the right track in
yeah it hard or was that guy [ __ ] up
that bad you know yeah the other guy was
an imbecile yeah um
and
the thing with biden is it's almost
it's like
a body switching movie
in that
he's
runs counter to everything he's stan
stood for his entire life
all that he's been like a hawk he's been
a deficit
uh hawk he's been a war hawk he's been a
deficit hawk
um he's been uh
kind of didn't care about
inclusion didn't care and now it's like
that's he doesn't that guy doesn't exist
but and he truly doesn't exist like i
really yeah
he doesn't it's not like they're
twisting his arm he's just like okay
i'll do that that's let's just go with
this and then i'll make policies to back
up the thing i said i would do like you
guys want actual morality okay
i was going with like catholic uh i ride
the train and
folks need morality and my son went to
georgetown and
this is like oh you want oh you want
actual morality not just lip service to
christianity it's really funny i some of
my friends are very very very far left
um
and a few of them
maybe in his first first month
were like just still kids at the border
what the [ __ ] are you gonna do about
that biden lies
it almost makes me
not everything should be done very
quickly you know and i'm not i don't
know exactly what's going on at the
border to make a determination but i
also don't want kids to be just
let out very quickly the first person
like
i didn't understand why
we weren't being patient i like not we
but when i see those opinions i'm like
dude give him a this is a huge [ __ ]
country
i like what he's doing i'm like yeah and
then as soon as they
obviously like raising awareness and
bringing it to like saying like you ran
on this
so what the [ __ ] are you gonna do about
it like that's good i like holding their
feet to the fire but then it's like like
today i read an article that they're
already starting to reunite families
with i'm like just anything towards
improvement that you said you would do
i do it's like i
most politicians don't do that [ __ ] you
know most politicians run
and get to a quarter
maybe fifty percent on what they said so
i like that
i mean i'm not sure what the
i don't think anyone i mean even aoc is
like he's exceeding my expectations
but
um
she did it when she was getting a bikini
wax she did it uh live and then you
really like why's she doing why is she
doing that
um the
the
the
[ __ ] like the border it's like ask those
friends exactly what should happen
that's
tell me exactly what i'm gonna send a
kid to your house what are you gonna do
when the kid doesn't speak english is
crying is dysregulated is upset and
disoriented
now what
what are you gonna do and it's again the
thing i would say about
with immigration ask the same people
once once they give you a fake answer on
that how many immigrants should we let
in a year right and how do you come to
that number
it's a [ __ ] fake they just go what's
wrong yeah it's wrong it was wrong for
them to come here the world's [ __ ]
crazy and it was wrong that they needed
to leave the country they it's like it's
a domino effect of wrong so do
do we have to then
just accept everything and and
and uh
not like welcome immigrants but it's
like how many it's a once you actually
other than like that makes me feel bad
right that's that's the thing but are
you doing the actual
research to understand how if the
problem was easily solved it would have
been done would have done it would have
been done been had done been solved so
but yeah i'm like like i'm liking a nice
boring
chill
yes
yeah it's just like a
sedative
he's on said it's the question it
sounded like a presence
look
his train speech was cracking me up um
when he yells look he's in trouble
uh he's gonna what i'm afraid is he's
gonna drown at some point he's he's just
gonna keep yelling look
instead of help
um because that's his go-to thing
um he's gonna be any stabbing
look
um
kamala do you see kamala so tim
the the republican guy
said america wasn't racist he had to
yeah well yeah
that is his only person he had to funny
thing is he said the progressives on the
left call me the n-word this is not a
racist country
okay
well that's funny i didn't know he said
that yeah he's like what about the
regressive he sounds like they are he
said i know what it's like to don't tell
me i'm
they call me [ __ ] they call me [ __ ]
and this is not a racist country i'm
like come on man oh so close yeah
where's this in canada
because
if they call you that and he also said
one time he's gotten pulled over seven
times in a year
it's like tim yeah yeah i'm just it's
okay you're okay it's not you he thinks
it's him
he thinks america's not a racist country
i'm just a piece of [ __ ]
be one person
tim i'm right there with you
now for kamala to hop on
that that [ __ ]
why why can't we just say it's so weird
that like
calling something racist
is something we reserve to the last like
don't no we gotta be really sure if it's
word looting and you can't don't loot
saying america's racist is like the red
line where it's like don't you dare say
so what what why not it's it's racist
what do you think red line like what do
you think all this [ __ ] how else would
you describe it it's not a moment
it's like it's not a mix-up but i don't
get why
why are we not just calling here's what
her not like the i understand here's
what i think her and biden are doing
they're gonna they're gonna legislate
like the leftiest left who'd ever left
right
but they're gonna talk like centrists
right to not so they're yeah so they're
just not they're not and they're also
not going to give the the right anything
to work with yeah because they're like
yeah like because they don't the right
doesn't really
they don't have any ideas legislatively
and trump did not he lower taxes that's
it and the wall but that's like not
that's the wall you lower the taxes for
for the rich people yeah um so
they don't have any legislative moves
uh so
they just have word moves they have like
the left is saying blank
so i think biden and kamala are just
going like no just like no no thank you
well it's also like well if everyone if
if we had four years of people lying to
our face
about
one thing i mean
no it's not racist like i don't yeah i
don't i if what she's doing is almost
like
you could say she's like gaslighting
conservatives yeah like she's
gaslighting conservatives where it's
like no
it's not racism here what are you
talking about like we're gonna pass a
george floyd anti-violence bill but not
because of racism
it's just because of uh
guide gravolitis as we all know
and uh
what is it um exhaust pipeline he had an
exhaust uh
acute gospel activity
a gas captivity
[Music]
um so i actually kind of like what like
kamala strikes me smart enough to know
what she's doing they know all everyone
knows when whatever you say well i don't
know what maybe tim doesn't know tim
doesn't know
he doesn't know i was like wait a minute
um but
kamala is smart enough to just it's like
then just don't give them any ammunition
and
just
i think they believe that people on the
right are ti people on the right and the
center and i'm gonna go ahead and say
the left are tired of hearing what
pieces of [ __ ] they are
they're just tired of it is this you
i'm officially tired of hearing what a
pizza should i have okay um
so
so yeah like just do something give it a
break and don't give him give him a rest
um
so
anyhow
you got that coven
uh
kovitz say what cover gone wild
um
indian i have india no good
india's not doing good india is doing so
bad uh
yeah their seven day average of new
cases per day is 373
000
which is
astounding
even in a country that big
um
they said they're on the brink of
collapse and just people dying in the
streets yeah
when india says hey the streets are
about to get wild
believe but homie believe it because the
streets are already wild in egypt in
egypt
god and uh where the [ __ ] am i no
india neil neil neil no get your racism
uh the yeah if [ __ ] is wild in india
[ __ ] is wild
uh because it's already
it's already wild so
the fact that we're fight i mean what do
you do what they're sending [ __ ] now
which i'm happy about
um
they're they're sending oxygen and
they're sending
they sent a million vaccines but yeah
they need a billion
you know
yeah they need all the back they need
all the vaccines that have been
distributed
we'll get to that in a second
um
yeah so they were actually you know how
like
in in countries where there's like a
martyr they'll put his pic they'll make
a poster and like a flag poster they
actually in india this week they had
posters of joe rogan because they were
so excited about what he said
encouraging americans not to take the
vaccine because they know
we get those vaccines now thank you mr
joe imagine the line thank you mr joe
but if a poo said it okay okay i'm not
[ __ ] on india right now i'm not gonna do
the accent
but imagine
imagine thank you mr joe
in that voice
um so yes you were saying darling um
i just
think
the world is going to be dealing with
code for a very long time
yes
it's not going away just because
apparently the
best place to be in the entire world is
in california
so in terms of uh
coveted rights really
it's the weird australia's i think
australia is probably doing better than
this but they could be in australia
though i mean in a good place
[Music]
is pretty good australia is on my pretty
high and my backup list really uh-huh
australia uh-huh why
melbourne and sydney have good climates
okay and i like australian women really
just generally speaking when they talk
like this
i like their attitudes they're not
prissy about it right now they're you
know what i say they're human first
women second
do you see that i do say that
originally it was about european women
but i but i say to the i say to the
women of australia
i will come eventually
um
and it will be wonderful when we finally
meet
and we and i make fun of stuff the local
that's how we're different i don't think
you're gonna like us really
have you been
no no just like you haven't no but i i i
just i can't explain it like you see it
and you go yeah i would like it there
but you know how many insects and
outsiders they're outsiders they don't
have an outside i heard
wait they got an outside there they're
outside they have the idol outside
you know what kind of outside they have
ding dong
call they got the dry
red and yellow one
likes a lot neal they're outside comes
inside spiders is big scorpions snakes
that i don't care about the neighborhood
kangaroo fights
that's my mma that's cool those [ __ ]
kangaroos
scrapping
on your lawn that's so not that's every
day y'all that's all day every that's 24
7. that's that's that's just that's that
life i want you to go to australia we
have to have one show dedicated to your
time there i we have uh two percent of
our audience from australia
i love the australia i like i like
australian women
this is the guy
oh no
uh no there's a guy you ever see the the
yeah the guy and then the oh no guy
parachutes down and
kangaroos immediately jump them
because they're like you know we're not
have you seen the guy that uh punched
him because the kangaroo was [ __ ]
with his dog yeah that's very funny this
oh my god this is so
funny he's parachuting down but
what's funny is he saw the uh he saw
them coming
and was like here they are they're
bouncing they're bouncing
hell no boop the [ __ ] you don't got it
oh my god that's so frightening we don't
play that parachute [ __ ]
um
kangaroos you will be my friends
and
it will be we will have a wonderful
night
three different australian women
over one month
now
i wish
i had an australian girlfriend for a
while
yeah did you like it yeah she's cool
um anyhow um
[Music]
did you see that cops this is the best
cops are afraid of getting
shots they cops are averse to the
they're always afraid in the most random
times but it's also like oh you don't i
thought you loved shots
um i've have i misread the news i
thought you guys were all about shots no
you don't uh they they had first access
and their
vaccination rates are lower than or
about the same as those of the general
public and they've had access for like
months longer so now what if a cop comes
to your window can you be like nah dude
yes you can i mean
i should amend that
if you're white i was like do not lead
our australians i'm sorry
i'm sorry if you're white of course
um yeah i'm not it's like i don't i mean
i
having said that i don't
i think they have to wear masks when
they approach your car okay and they're
outside yeah
so
you know and plus the cops don't have
the balls to pull me over
that's one of my favorite jokes to do so
when a cop's following me and then he
just turns off i got didn't think so
coward
just to yourself to your silent audience
yeah to my to my unseen audience that i
put a camera in my car to log jokes like
that at night but it's too big of a pain
to get them off
i had big plans for my wow for neil
brennan.com
the lost tapes it really could have been
something guys
um
anyhow
what you mean no more hurting me we're
not going to get there how do you know
google is
headlining the times and the post today
we're never going to get there we were
promised her we weren't reaching heard
is unlikely it's unlikely
it's basically gonna be the flu which is
fine they just have to keep vaccinating
uh
the
old the old yeah
and it'll it's kind of seasonal like the
flu
um and
it's manageable
well you know here's the thing
when any population of any species gets
bigger and bigger you just get more
diseases and viruses to take them out
that's just what happened so i feel like
we're probably gonna have more of this
in the future you know
like besides coronavirus now it's gonna
be and then those faces sweetheart it's
so good i don't know why i'm calling you
sweetheart today you do that done too i
don't call you sweetheart on the air
very much you do it
it's all abuse it's uh you do when
you're being um you're about to like you
when you're being constantly when i'm
being caused yeah it's signal yeah put
your windshield
put your windshield up daddy's getting
ready to be condescending uh yeah it's
not gonna it's not gonna be it's just
gonna be manageable and
the sad thing is we're gonna have to
keep talking about this [ __ ] thing
for another
forever
forever this is a ripple effect and then
there's gonna be places in africa and
latin america and
ireland nation stay away from travel
warnings travel warnings or you know
they just don't get
the they just it's gonna take them years
to get a vaccine and
i don't know yeah just it's just really
highlighting and exploiting how
uh
we as human beings aren't doing a good
job of taking care of each other
well
this like i said last week
i don't i don't hear anyone in the west
complaining about
hoarding vaccines
i've heard some people
saying
uh
like i think we even talked about but i
heard it outside of us
all the anti-vaxxers like just
cool you have a month to get a vaccine
we have two months and then there will
be no more vaccines for you until oh
that's great no but i'm saying
people on the left who are all about you
know
uh privilege and all that stuff when
they got a little priv vax privilege
they were they're kind of fine with it
oh yeah american supremacy like it was
so clear yeah when we had all the facts
yeah they have no problem somehow
they're they got vaccinated from their
morals
that's one of the side effects is your
morals you kind of have it before and
then when you get it you really have it
um which good good for y'all see that's
why just admit that you're kind of
immoral just make your life easier
make your life easier i'm trying to join
us kind of sex is kind of raised it's
kind of big and it kind of it's fine i'm
working on it but it's hard are you
yeah i'm too relaxed you're so defensive
no
because i spoke to
i spoke to kat about this this weekend
because we're like working a lot like
[ __ ]
and
i was kind of saying that
as a guy
now almost every interaction i have with
a woman now i'm screening myself for
sexism all the time
every single
positive well no it doesn't it no i it's
not
i don't feel like you're an actively
sexist i know but when you read all the
woke [ __ ]
what you could walk away with is like
i'm a [ __ ]
virulently racist sexist bigot
yeah
and
i personally am on the low end of it but
i still because my diet is just
i'm trying to do a joke like i my mom
last year read a book called i'm a white
piece of [ __ ] she didn't know no she
didn't but like that's basically like
everyone on the left was reading these
[ __ ]
what's the [ __ ] europe white piece of
[ __ ] basically i like it um
so
so i i just every
every interaction with a
a non-white person i'm like
ah and you just it just gets
i'm not gonna i'm just complaining about
it i'm not gonna change okay but i am
complaining and then and then you don't
help
with that tone
with that okay screen yourself neil uh
screen you're
you're getting your screen on my screen
um
okay so the i mentioned it in the india
but joe rogan i don't know if you saw
the clip friend of the show friend of
the show friend of the show promo the
show has apparently
had me on when we first started
um well his background's gotten so tech
he's like barbecue joint texas
it's one of those things where this is
why you shouldn't let guys decorate
anything
yeah just you just shouldn't
like guys don't we just i have i do it a
joke uh that men decorate like fugitives
from the law
like we just decorate like we don't know
we don't know how to do it and the stuff
we do know is like wood and neon
it's just based on it most when guys put
together colors it's we think about
football teams or we think about sports
scenes always primary colors always
primary colors that's like the bears and
then
uh
and then wood reclaimed wood has been a
boom for man in the last 10 10 years
and then of course neon and
texas
um i'm sure somebody made it for him um
no i know it's just funny yeah like he
is really in texas right now
so he said it was taken out of context i
don't know the exact
the bigger issue is to me
he said we'll just tell him what he said
he said so joe said that
uh if
he were going he if he were if a 21 year
old a healthy 21 year old
who was like healthy
asked him
if they should take the vaccine he would
say no um
now
that's wrong
that is scientifically wrong to the
point that you said something about it
which is [ __ ] hilarious like a bunch
of people uh and and the press secretary
at the white house said something about
it about joe's quote specifically
now the funny thing is
this is not joe's fault
no
it is the fault of
institutions if this happened at john
stewart right around 2000 2001 2 3
john started to realize
that young people were getting their
news from him
and he
they i know specifically he fought it
for a little bit and then was finally
like [ __ ] all right i mean you came home
from school and you turned on the daily
show uh i don't
i wasn't in school
thanks
yes i wasn't in school you turned on you
came home from working on chappelle show
you went to sleep
you didn't want to watch comedy center
it was kind of the last thing you wanted
to watch as a matter of fact um
so
like the fact checker there's a guy that
works in the daily show named chad's
who's been there
probably before the the absolute
fact-checking thing that i'm talking
about before john was like [ __ ] all
right who was who hosted it before john
craig kilbourne oh yeah so nobody it
wasn't that was just like a lot of
entertainment jokes and
and then
so
it's a failure of church media
government
um and that's why all the comedians then
this is part of the thing i'm working on
that's why comedians are
so exalted and so listened to for
vaccine advice because they're not in
the pocket of
pharma whatever government government
yeah but everyone in the government's in
the pocket of pharma yeah everyone in
pharma are just greedy
everyone in uh church
were [ __ ] children
and everyone in media are
in it for themselves yeah so and i think
people slowly realize that it's like
chris is joking sorry alive like
the reason
he never saw walter cronkite in shorts
like that but everyone has to be an
entertainer now it's just like a [ __ ]
degradation of the whole thing so
a guy like joe becomes people's main
source of a ton of information and joe
himself has his own biases and
stupid opinions like he said the next
day yeah i don't even listen to myself
right he's like that was me what did he
say he was like uh that was
like don't lose me in a more like
something like yeah he's like i he
basically i don't even listen myself
which is a bit of what john played for a
while and just finally
put the sword down and was like okay
this is a new show
it's a new show that you know i need to
be funny but
it's got to be
uh
vetted yeah more than i'm betting it
before so joe's never gonna do that
because the appeal of the show was just
a guy
talking well also it's the fact that
there's also a
an issue of the fact that why are people
why is joe saying an opinion on his
podcast
making i don't know why it is but that's
a problem i mean joe can be
have one opinion
one day and just change it he did it on
bernie he did it on trump i mean like
yeah he's just a guy he's just a guy
he's just a guy but we and we talked
about it before how we just elevate
celebrities to this deity status like
well joe said it and because so many
people do that now when he says
something
falsies got to respond yeah that's so
weird
like let joe to have his [ __ ] opinion
without us all losing our [ __ ]
like even when he said popular he's too
popular but even when he said bernie
even when he said trump then
vaccines and but bernie was a hard one
for his audience
there are things where he's like all in
for bernie right and then a portion of
an audience is like i'm not voting for
some old jewish socialists right
whereas trump was like that's better
what do you mean it's good that
people can discern between joe rogan's
opinion and their own yes but that
normally it's joe will say i'm voting
for trump because biden's old which is
is was factually true but i don't think
that was good enough reason to not vote
for him um
and
and people can it's
with
it's an easy a lot of these a lot of
these um
media outlets a lot of bubbles that we
all live in
fox news even msnbc for the left
they are skinny mirrors for our
what we want to think about our body
right so i don't want to [ __ ] get i
don't want to schedule a vaccine
i don't want to go i don't like needles
and then joe goes i wouldn't get if i
was healthy 21 year old and you go i'm
40 and fat but close enough
close enough i want i i don't want
basically i didn't want to get it and
now i have a reason not to get it yeah i
don't even worship joe it's just a guy
that
a guy that they're like
pretty cool with
yeah they like um
yeah so
but it's very
it's just interesting how
kind of how you outlined where we're now
where people are getting their news from
i mean i know people who are
the biggest fans of you that they listen
to our podcast for our take
and more importantly your take on news
and then they
then take your opinion
and that's where they center themselves
around in their friends they're good
people but they you know and then they
that's their opinion in their friend
group yeah no i get that's jim jeffries
did that joke of like you say the things
i want to say but
don't have the guts like no you didn't
think of it yeah i did
and it's not guts so the the only
difference between you and me is guts
right
so you thought of jim jeffery's gun
control bit you just didn't have the
balls to say it yeah and i know people
who do that listen to the podcast that
regurgitate your
opinion because
they trust you enough to vet yourself
that's what i was hoping you would do
but boy was i wrong go ahead boy was i
ripped off one of the biggest catfishes
of all time hey hey hey so um
they
take your opinion but because
they already feel like you you will do
the vetting
for the opinion that's and and i think
and i think that about joe 100 it's like
well joe
brings on
the he doesn't bring on a doctor he
brings on the number one doctor in that
field you know and but then he'll also
bring on the guy
right he'll also bring on the guy who's
not a doctor of course and or is kind of
a doctor but not a medical doctor right
he'll have opinions and then people will
go that's easier and flatters me more
that's the skinny mirror i'm looking for
where like oh i'm skinny now i don't
have to do [ __ ] yeah and
uh and i'm a different kind of skinny
mirror
yeah it's all skinny mirrors but it's
just it's
i don't know it's interesting you know
but the thing i'll say
i will acknowledge my biases like last
week where i was like i have a
confession to make
i'm gonna side with black people a lot
more than
most people would
uh because i can't not
like i oh it's not even anything me and
dave ever discussed like you know i need
your stuff but it's just i can't
you know um
so
guys take my black opinions and just
knock 40 off of them and that's where
you're gonna that's and then regurgitate
that
um but it's not it's not joe's fault
um and he has a different
opinion about
the responsibility hit what
responsibility he has
and
um
[Music]
should he correct for this size of an
audience
because i don't think it's it's like
it would be like nwa getting very
popular and be like maybe not [ __ ] the
police that's right maybe not [ __ ] the
police right it's just like
we have problems just say there's
tension
i think
i think joe would have that opinion and
it would be roughly the same show if it
was popular or unpopular that's the
point it's he's not changing right he
i've known him 30 years he's not this is
who he is right so he is so
should he be required to change because
he's now
extremely popular yeah i don't know
yeah i mean i can make an argument
yes and no i'm way more in the no column
he should not have changed but i could
30 of me is like
yeah maybe
if you're if you're saying [ __ ] that
gets you know if you're that big of a
voice but then it's not fun
it's not fun and you know he also did a
bunch of things that were also popular
besides his podcast and no one was
asking you know and still was the same
person you know yeah
fear factor guy you know what i mean
like i think we'd care a lot less if i
wanted to change back then
i thought he should i thought it was
rude that he kept asking people to eat
uh
moose eyeballs and testicles and stuff
um but tyrone bigums
um
[Music]
buffets i don't know if you saw no
back
uh
may 7th new jersey
buffets are back only in new jersey
bianca may not be here next week guys
she's gonna be
and the golden corral
freehold newton freehold
she'll be signing
plates
um tiny ones are five dollars big ones
are ten
she'll be signing them at the freehold
golden corral
um so because they realized it's not
nothing's from the surface and yeah
more importantly even the small amount
that were from surfaces
very rarely was it from food like almost
was never from food right but was it
from
tongs i think the buffet isn't going to
be
everyone grabs the same tongue
why not going to be one person doing it
with gloves and ppe
pp
what's your problem bareback
raw dog buffet which maybe i'll open
neil brennan's bareback raw dog buffet
meatless
because i'm not a climate denier anyways
the thing is
so at whole foods the buffet area now is
one guy who's trapped
he's trapped between two buffet
things yeah and he'll give you what you
want
i know but okay but what about when you
get oh
you're gonna not like this but when you
get a slice of prime rib
let me go in my way back machine yeah
go back to
norbit yeah
yeah uh you know i get it it's carving
station it's an omelette station it's
parking station what's the problem with
that i i don't like waiting for those
people
i want exactly here's the other thing i
want
that strawberry i want that like that i
want specific don't i don't want
if strawberry i am when it comes to
strawberries
i am a segregationist no whites i don't
want any white [ __ ] uh the white inside
top top cap
white no white white white no white caps
on my strawberries don't want it do not
want it guys bring that in your friend
group spread it around
no white caps
um
yeah so i'm excited
for you what's going on in vegas a lot
of people are booking shows in vegas i
know that vegas has been back i feel
like secretly now it's like very back
it's like we kind of never stopped a
little bit yeah they shut down for like
maybe six weeks but not and it's
no one was really going but i think now
they're going oh i think this summer is
going to be wild
covet 20
21 baby um i think it's gonna be
um
and guys you just so you know
you can catch hpv and covet on the same
weekend i thought the vaccines were both
two for one nah no they you got a what's
the other one uh
the other the hpv one oh that's a
guardian epipen what gardasil
that's the epipen no epipens from when
you're having an allergic reaction well
don't ask me to help you need something
if joe biden
he's gonna go look and you're gonna hit
him with an epipen meanwhile he's got
hpv he said look when he gets yeah when
anything bad happens good look
um i learned a lot well you got to
replace i learned a lot with look
because it took me five episodes before
i knew who that was of oh really i knew
it immediately i had no idea who that
was
gunpop was a bad dude that's a good one
no that's great because no one else has
ever said corn pop it's true um
who wasn't in part it wasn't in
riverdale look
um
oh bill gates
that's a little no i just wrote it down
extra because it's such hot fresh news
tell me getting divorced
no melinda he is gonna be [ __ ]
crushing so much
he's gonna need his own vaccine for the
amount of eight for the amount of stds
he's gonna be doing so much gardasil um
he's yeah he's uh
which again
ladies if you want to be incredibly rich
marry a dork and wait
that's all you got to do imagine if that
dork though imagine for the wrong i know
you picked the wrong dork you picked the
wrong dork that's on you
but if you pick the right dork and
give it a second
you will oh my god what happened what's
the tea hot goddess tell me uh i just
he's a he's a crabby little guy i think
ask your one friend
i don't know anyone who knows i mean
trevor knows a little bit the one
billionaire he doesn't know that one oh
he doesn't know that um
i said something to somebody about
trevor
he might be
if there was one guy
in the world trevor noah
that
more women in the world want to sleep
with
he might be on the top five
i'm talking about in the world africa
south america australia
europe
asia
north america
uh anybody i'm missing antarctica i feel
like that guy from bridgeton also is
i didn't haven't seen a frame no one
knows him i'm not saying if they see him
i'm seeing well because bridgette was so
huge right but it's not as big as trevor
no no trevor is very so
he's great looking like every it just
was so popular because of him yeah
and apparently they offered him 50k an
episode and he is leaving for the second
season he's just like bye-bye he can
make he can make that on the bachelor
i mean honestly like 50 grand yeah i was
like 50 grand in episode just like go
[ __ ] yourself
um
he's so good so and his name's rey gay
so that's fun um right there that's fun
does he give it maybe he's great looking
uh trevor i think has probably more
appeal than him because women think
they're the only one who likes trevor
it's really weird i'm like jeffrey's
extremely good looking yeah go to jail
kelly the grammy one
um
yeah that grammy phone with the new with
the with the nice fro but the nice
jay-z
2017 fro uh yeah i just think trevor's
got to be on the list of like well he's
everyone smart he's smart he's cute and
he's nice he's nice smiles dimples hair
i think who i guess athletes would be on
the list
if they don't that guy that the guy with
his shirt off i feel like athletes don't
count because it's such a like they're
here for a good time in a long time yeah
i think but
uh when we went to my friend who's in
love with him when we went to the show
you set us up with tickets
the in between
when the a commercial break
between the things so
so
charismatic hello hello welcome to the
daily show there was like a there's like
a little bit of like some african
aunties in the front row that he spoke
to there's at taping the daily show
there's always at least three hit jobs
now
literally every single episode i've ever
seen and i pointed out to one of the
writers who like it's he i we started
saying his audience is malala
that's stupid like
just
just like every
young it's just he just so [ __ ]
appealing but then he does this
brilliant thing which is
it's crowd work but it's really smart so
he's just like a question in the
audience yeah just what do you think of
blitz
harassment he just says something
brilliant
and also like winking at the aunties and
yeah
what's funny is that's and then while
he's doing that they walk me out to do a
like to do one of the pieces and it's
just like boo basically
it's like this my friend neil and one
person will go like
three mikes
trevor talk extemporaneously again
a billion women would sleep with him
tonight
two nights i believe that i believe you
could get a billion women to sign on a
bill i don't know what for charity will
do it
um i had another thing i want to say it
you know how some people are like
shower people
like they always look like they just
took a shower
i
cat pointed out that i seem like that
because of the show
as a shower person
and i want you to know that i only
shower right before the show
and
um so i'm not like one of those
wet-haired people
yes okay get what you're saying tell me
what i mean like where you're like how
are you how's your always awesome you
have a good example trevor's not a bad
example of it but uh
he doesn't know it's people who look a
little
glimmery yeah on the like eyelash hair
yeah uh
there's a good one and i can't remember
who it is
um anyhow alice and janie always looks
like she just took a shower
gavin newsome
is not it's close it's getting there
yeah i mean it's just product we know we
did that
um
so
you know this didn't get picked up very
much but ahmad aubry the people the guys
who shot him got
charged with the hate crime yes
yesterday which is like racist three
yeah
now okay here's the question
um
uh the opposite of trevor noah those
three look um
here's the question yeah yeah
no it looks they're similar to trevor
character-wise um
the
criminal justice reform yes
does having
extra punishment for hate crimes
i think it runs counter to criminal
justice reform right
and
and then uh my other argument against
hate hate crime bill it's just kind of
pandering to the
just
have them do the [ __ ] time like but
sometimes you can get someone on one and
not the other
oh is that okay i don't know you know so
adding the more to it it just ups the
chance of like
cool we can get them for this
thing exactly and
i don't know i think depending on
where you are in your sentencing like
it gives you actually more time you know
what i mean i don't know like obviously
well that's what i'm saying like what's
the what is the
so if they can't get them on murder one
or whatever let's just say jury wise
they can get them on other things so i
don't i don't have a full problem with
it but i'm sure there's ways it
maybe feels like pandering like i
understand why it feels like pandering
but
i
like every crime in some ways is a hate
crime
just about every murder is a hate i mean
you know what i mean like it's not
you're not doing it for any other but
there is like the only reason why we
have hate crimes like what if it's just
white guys going out and looking for a
black person to kill yes now
what if it's the opposite
my the argument is
when we talk about criminal justice
reform i think most people think
uh black or brown people convicted of
drugs
and
do is that all we want
does punishment work
are we incarcerating them are we
rehabilitating them are we it's that
stuff that we only think applies to
black or brown men
or women who whatever like can't make
bail what all the [ __ ] that's
absolutely wrong and we think well we'll
fix that
what about
murderers
like are we gonna give them lower
sentences are we going to try to
rehabilitate them are we going to try to
put them in a different category well
this country's so [ __ ] a lot of a lot
of places in the world 25 years is the
max you get uh-huh
that's what i mean that's what i mean
not our 25 years sounds low to us from
murder it's like only 25 years yeah he
didn't get lifetimes multiple life times
consecutive negative it's like he got
592 years like guys come on we supersize
it like we do everything
so
i do think that
one we can't really be in favor of
rehabilitation in this country if we
also
we we're like you're a criminal you
can't get a job right we're like we're
we're we're both
calvinist
and like you're getting seven million
years right and then we try to be
christian it's like we should think
about what we're doing right
like we'll pick do you want to speak to
the family yeah it's like yeah
yeah so that's the contradiction of
all this stuff now i i'm very happy that
they're
that they're what they did was atrocious
it's just
you know the death penalty [ __ ] like who
who deserves what and how did you come
to that i think the problem is it it so
rarely works this way
that when we it hasn't worked yet that's
the other thing well it doesn't work but
it even it so rarely gets to this point
you know to hate crime it's actually
really hard to pin
federal hate charges on somebody so when
it does happen it i
it and i'm not this is not a criticism
of you but that's when we want to talk
about is this even effective what is it
it's one person when it's the opposite
way is when we want to talk about
these like rules and do they work and
are they should there be exceptions
should they even like we're talking
about it now yeah you know what i mean
well i'm living in this world of like
what is pot what's the right we're
living in a different world right now
yeah like what is the what should we do
right for these people what i i don't
there's also the thing it's kind of the
joke i do about
i don't know what the [ __ ] sentences
are and i'm not not killing people
because of the sentence
do you know what i mean i'm not like man
35 years i don't got that i want to kill
you so bad
but i don't got 35 years to give away
it's just i don't want to kill somebody
right
so then it becomes the
victims it's politicians and the victims
families
yeah the victims families want revenge a
lot of the time sometimes they don't but
most of the time most of the time it's
like burn and i hope he burns in there
yep so
a lot of it's a time to kill
yes so what do we i don't know what do
you [ __ ]
are you drawing any conclusions through
the research you're doing through the
pod um
uh that's what i mean no it's just
people are
americans don't want the most effective
system
no
they don't the most effective system is
yeah it's like the most effective system
is
sweden
what are you looking for not uh sweden
sweden yeah
uh sweden um
what are you looking what are you
looking to get out of this
well as a as a country and that you know
we say we want rehabilitation but i
watch this documentary it was so
interesting
um
because it was about child molesters and
sex offenders and how do we want to
rehabilitate them
and um what it's a documentary yeah it
was really good should i yeah yeah um so
it it followed a few of them but one of
the guys
owned a company and he was like the only
reason
i'm not so a lot of the guys just end up
living in the woods which is so
frightening oh it's very funny so it's
funny it's so frightening imagine you
walk up on like
sex
they seem like child molesters
so they all um
so because of certain laws a lot of the
time they can't be in certain counties
right and they can't be near certain
they can't be
so they can only
rent in certain places then you have oh
wait
there's a there's a trailer park right
that's the what the documentary is about
there's a there is a documentary about a
trailer park
that is i can't remember that
not that one okay and it showed them all
three different guys getting um
that are done with their sentence and
now they have to do like living their
life after spending time in jail for
their sex
offenders yeah because they go you need
to check in in every neighborhood
that you move to and let your neighbors
know the weird thing was
explaining to a squirrel
what a sex offender is
but these guys had to go around to all
the animals neal the squirrels the birds
the owls were like fine
we get it
um no so basically which is when you see
it's like what do you what do we want
these guys to do because we want them
to do
we
based on all these city ordinances in
the state blah blah
it seemed like we wanted to tie them up
and drop them at the bottom of the ocean
yeah
we don't want you here we don't want you
we don't want to rehabilitate you we
don't want to think about your problem
we want you to dribble up and die and
it's hard because
you watch the documentary and you feel
bad but then these are people that have
they're rapists or you know child
sex
assaulters
so and it was just interesting the one
guy that ended up the best was a guy
that had his own construction company
and he could buy
a little run he can get a rental in a in
the perfect kind of county where he
could be close to where he has to check
in
and i don't know it just was it was just
there
what do we do with these people almost
like homeless people
yeah houseless but but but way worse
way worse but still
people who cannot get a job yeah and
cannot live anywhere really yes even
though these people would say
[ __ ] them
and they do they live in scary and they
live in the woods in a tent yes
it was in florida this
well
so that's
that's i feel like a lot of people yeah
um
there's like uh most of the like
probably 800 000 people in florida live
in the woods
in some form
emotionally you know what i mean
um
so i don't know it's just interesting
thinking about like hate crimes and
hate crimes and extra
things but also criminal justice reform
like
well then we just passed a
anti-asian
crime bill
yeah which then you're like wasn't hate
crime
all crime against race yeah and also the
interesting thing about the
which i don't know if we discussed the
guy who
stomped
the asian lady on video oh the guy that
was like killed his mom yeah he was he
did
he did time for killing his mom he did
how is he out he did 18 years but that's
the thing in my head i'm like why would
you be on the streets if you could yeah
because
it because he costs 48 000 a year to
keep in jail and uh maybe he learned his
lesson well that's the thing don't you
always bring up the fact that most
people murder only murder ones
they don't take it out people don't like
it
um
and this is another from the from the
what the [ __ ] do we do file
uh caitlyn jenner
said that trans girls
shouldn't play sports shouldn't play
girls girl sports
and um
so if he
she believes that
how confused do you think i am just as a
person like ha that
she has the wrong opinion
and
she's she's a trans athlete she's a
trans she's the most famous trans
athlete of all time
and she doesn't think it's right so it's
like as a nor as a just a regular
walking around heterosexual
white man
i don't [ __ ] know like i i don't i
don't even know how to make the
calculation
what happens is sometimes
a uh
boy or man will
um
uh transition to a girl or woman right
and then
they'll be playing sports with a boy's
body
somewhat
and against women yeah and
there was i believe a wrestler
a couple of the women have just
destroyed the competition yeah they also
just listened to tony henschel's bed he
like details it perfectly yeah like the
examples there's an mma woman there's a
there's uh
and they just
destroy their uh
a lot of times i listen to a debate
about a lot of times they don't
but a lot of times they don't yeah
that's the thing a lot of the time
that's how bad they were as male
athletes is they can't even
you see that you can't even get behind
that joke
um
uh
so
so yeah like
so as a just a walking around person
what are the odds i'm gonna have the
right opinion about this but this begs
the question we
why this is and i'm gonna quote you
such a small problem it is such a small
percentage of our population right
that but if you're at a
i don't think there's a massive amount
of trans athletes entering
either
biological
i think it's minor but they're not
talking about professional they're
talking about high school college grade
school
and this is again i don't know i
literally will never know i could live
to be a thousand and i will not know the
right ideas lawmakers can't cite local
examples of trans girls in sports so
yeah yes there are plenty of
uh
it is a small problem but for the people
it's a problem for it's actual problem
and
what how should the people
involved make a decision about it how
should that government or that the
governing body of that league no oh yeah
i don't know that's to me i'm like i
don't know are pay grade yes because i
there's too many factors and i
a lot of it rests in biology
a lot of it is biological it's like
you're inside your body
is it like once you go through hormones
and once you do this and that doesn't
have the ability is this pre-hormone
transition is it just identity is it
you know when a fetus becomes a person
i
don't know there we go i don't know i
don't know
i can't even pretend to know good thing
is we don't have to know that well
i got something to talk to you about
he's like okay
real problem you got 80 bucks
um
newsmax apologized to the dominion
the guy that they were lying on the one
they had to say like look i love that we
have a issue
and it's the dominion like they just
lied about it how funny that was like
you get a 1.9 billion lawsuit wait no
no no no yeah yeah billion dollars
they're like they
they they directly they posted a thing
on their website no evidence no evidence
um the guy basically they charged the
dem uh they kept saying on newsmax and
fox news
that
one
a few specific employees at dominion
voting
through the election for
for
uh biden and they lied about trump votes
and they kept saying it
there were examples like yep yep that
happened and then
they had to then they they got sued by
dominion the company worked for for 1.8
billion dollars right billion would it
be yeah and it's like it's gonna be a
case it's not like this apology is not
no
this is not the apology's feckless
because the damage is done
and
i hope they lose
i hope they burn i hope they burn in
hell
yes they deserve to pay
i hope they burn in hell
um
anyhow so good for you dominion guy yeah
the good news is i don't know your name
i read it as dominant okay dominance
what did domino do oh domino the rapper
domino oh oh
here we go domino
uh dock watch
[Music]
it's a good song that's so good that's
the only one that's make the length is
good
yeah it could be a little shorter a
little bit but it's it it's there's a
reason yeah it's we let it look we let
it we let it slide cool look hey hey
man we smoke grass
we live in the park
we live in the in the forest and we
talked to the animals
um then we smoke dupes and uh
don't google us
because you're not gonna like the
results
uh
did you watch couples therapy season two
yeah did you watch no i'm on episode
nine actually i think i'm done
they only did nine i was waiting to hear
from you if it's still good yeah okay
it's very good it's just a good [ __ ]
idea for yourself it was good
and they wanted me to because i
am publicly a fan
they wanted no they wanted me to tweet
out an invitation for people to be on it
like a casting thing and i was like i
don't want to do that you need to pay
for the you're okay sponsors um
yeah so
so
it's just amazing it's just
amazing to watch people in relationships
yeah
trying to make it work when it shouldn't
or when it could but
men like looks fake let's face men and
women do not belong together
no it's just hard
it's just like greek antiquity they did
have different
they had a jewish like kind of or modern
orthodox jewish couple
who
the
they really liked each other
which was like
very palpable the other couples
i wouldn't bet money on
one of the guys was a train conductor
which i'd never you never seen like
hammock therapy
um and
there was the interesting thing was that
it was a i don't know if they were
dominican or they were latino and
the
guy and girl and
the girl was just
the ho she was the hard one
and just wasn't was just kind of cold
and mean and it was very interesting to
watch interesting yeah um instead of the
clown and he had his own like
kind of guy
habits but she was very
cold and mean it was fun to watch it's
fun to watch it therapists break that
like i was like oh i know this type
and then it turned out to be true um
is it there do you think there's a point
because i feel like
relationships are i don't know they're
made out of glass like they're very
durable but they're also really fragile
too like
what point
do you think every relationship can come
back from i haven't found glass durable
well i mean like it's everywhere in your
house it's in your windshield that's
plastic you idiot no
but it we use it in places where we
really need something to be durable
um
i don't i still hear it as a when like
mr glass wasn't about a durable guy it
was about a guy i mean i don't know if
you're going to go look if you're going
to go to mm-hmm on sam jackson movies
like why like why what are you even what
are you what even are you doing
um but i'm just saying relationships how
much can
do you think do you think every
relationship can bounce back if
everybody really wants to make it work
or do you think there's some things that
it's just too far gone i just i don't i
think people either have chemistry
i think you can have chemistry with
somebody that's incredible
and that can end yeah you can have
social chemistry and then at a certain
point it just becomes like
like we've talked about falling out of
love with somebody it's [ __ ]
terrifying and it's terrifying because
you were like what it was right here
i had it right here right i left it on
my nightstand
um so
i don't know
i think people's expectations for
relationships are incredibly high and i
think if there were no
children
right it would be
what would relationships look like if
children just were like seeds we planted
in a forest i mean it would be
so much more
i think both parties would be
completely different
the amount of just [ __ ] guys
it's like women can take
uh thing and twist it into a plot
against them right
guys can do a thing where they
the amount of dumb excuses guys have for
reasons
of like well no i want to see you but
like
not right now
but like i do
want just the amount of just dumb
[ __ ] guys are capable of yeah is
kind of astounding
it's a lot of lying it's a lot of lying
to not hurt the other person's feelings
everyone's capable of that though i know
i'm not saying yeah i'm not saying that
women are not no yeah oh sorry i don't
know what you were saying but yeah that
everyone is
but that's the thing some people are
not
lying to her some people i've
experienced people that
have
like the inner voice is just outside of
the brain it's like don't say all of
that
be quiet
it's enough like it's fine i thought you
were going to say that people
are they're lying to themselves like
they don't even know
that they're lying that's a thing too
but some people over share
the anxiety
and end up saying things that they don't
even [ __ ] mean yeah but it's just
like well no i just thought like
it's like
okay i'm not gonna forget anything you
just said yeah you might
but i'm gonna remember what you just
said why you saying that so
i don't know it seems whoever
whoever thought of human beings the baby
thing is the thing like what would it be
like like there's a show on hbo the
nevers which is about women
in i don't know what year it is but it's
the one where they have magic yeah but
it's a cool idea though
yeah there was a book
um uh what's the point of it actually
the point of it is
i believe it's based on the book uh the
uh the power it was based on a book the
power i believe
maybe i'm wrong i mean it's not if it's
not based on the powers they rip the
power off
um
uh
right there the never spaced on a book
well it never isn't based on oh that's
interesting okay
um the
it's base the power is women
can basically tase men with their hands
yeah i saw like i saw the first half but
it's interesting if every woman could do
that
male female relationships are
entirely different well it's a power
thing you can kill me
yes yes
right
and men now can i contage you with my
hands
more or less yeah you just as a man nice
bigger better muscles women and with
this bowflex forget about it
women are we fall in love with we date
and we
have sex with
beings that can murder murder us and do
murder us a lot yup so
there's already that already the it's a
already it's a great
first dress it's a great script
uh yeah so
so i you know the baby thing i think
men would be less evasive and women
would be less
the ticking clock is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's just uh it makes it
unbe it makes it very difficult for
women
to
just have a an appraisal of men
that isn't based on like but i kind of
want to ah and
hedging and like uh maybe let me see
i get married marriage is like a and
they would also get rid of marriage
because that's the point of marriage is
making a making that child uh legitimate
that always makes me laugh like the
child wasn't legitimate like what
i also have a theory i have i don't ever
told you the light and license for the
marriage license yeah is a [ __ ]
license
that's it that's the only new thing
right you can [ __ ] now
go to the church right
enjoy the [ __ ] yeah that's it that's
the only thing that's in taxes i guess
yeah but that's it but it's a [ __ ]
license that's so funny they should call
it that
i feel like more of you you may [ __ ] the
bride you may i mean that's kind of the
i mean that's basically what they're
saying like you'll kiss here
but you know they're [ __ ] though
they can this is all this is all
legitimate now
the [ __ ] it's sanctified
god says
[ __ ]
and
[ __ ]
um
couples therapy anyhow
um good show watch at showtime season
two go back watch season one season
one's great they did they even did a
covet special it was good i think that's
why they only had nine episodes because
they added a cove it's special
um
last chance you i love you they did a
basketball version which i like better
because i like basketball yeah um and i
think i like basketball players better
do you like do they also have a crazy
like uh wiggery white coach
no they have a i liked him he was funny
uh they have a black coach oh cool and
he's
like one of those like slam well you got
to get up in his you got to get in his
face i like a
angry coach
he's very angry
but not like angry he's just like what
stop it
like crawling on the floor and like
just he's a he's a he's a bit of a drama
queen right uh
and
it's funny there's a point where they're
all playing video games and they're in
there
and they're 19 and i'm still of the mind
of like all these guys are older than me
somehow funny because they're so much
bigger than me right that it was a long
time before i would watch
sports and go
college sports especially i still think
professional athletes are older than me
well lebron james is 50. 15 years older
than me
easily
and
blake
blake's young but like i had to like you
had to
like in order for me to think he's
younger than me
i had to see him do young you know what
i mean i've seen his first half like
just like dumb guy [ __ ] but
you couldn't tell me i mean chris paul's
25 years older than me no he's not oh no
of course
but they're all i love him yeah and then
when they retire it's like oh
steve nash is about my age
before that he was
he was way older he was biden
but now he's he's about my age uh it's
because framing and associations
good [ __ ] i never watched last chance
you and i
uh it's good i've only watched one yeah
but they're an hour each that was yeah
you yeah they're long well i don't was
the first one like that maybe but the
first last chance he was really good
and then
i don't know it's kind of confusing
they bounce around to different schools
and stuff but oh they do okay but it was
lasting chance you that
i realized that um
how much
racism plays still in paul you know how
like
in
college sports it's like oh you know it
seems like on the up and up but
the school that they were at
just barely let in people from
let them transfer kids like let them
recruit kids from different states and
like out of town kids because otherwise
it doesn't give the white football
players a chance
because they just over recruit too many
good players and so they talked about
that a lot in the first one
like the racist aspects of it so it was
just it was interesting it's not as
purely
uh
it's just not purely football as you'd
think well that's what when last year i
don't know if i talked about this but
during the george floyd thing
an agent called me and a hollywood agent
called me oh wow and was like
a white guy and he was like
look somebody just got promoted in my
company
i think she only got promoted because
she's black
and like
it bothers me it's that make me racist i
was like and i go
i don't even know the guy well i was
like
eat it
i and he's like wha i go
have you ever watched an nba game why do
you think every team has at least one
white guy on the bench right
it's [ __ ] affirmative action
for the fans
to g and he was like
really
i'm like yes it's like do you think
[ __ ] brian scalibrani's the best
player that celtics could get and by the
way that's a whole other argument but
like because he there he's a great
basketball player i'm sure
i kind of think that there were better
guys that were interested that were
darker complex do you think that is
very prevalent i think that it's i
i don't know if every team has it
because it's boston so i'm like right
yeah i mean i kind of believe that
pretty much every team in the nba has a
white guy
a kind of token like i i maybe i'm maybe
i'm over there i know they used to i
know like in the 90s they absolutely did
right i think i think probably now it
varies from team to team was there an
obvious one like this guy didn't belong
in the team
uh
the balls had a few big whites
but they played bill weddington and
coach and um
purdue
the funniest thing is they all become
announcers
every one of them all the whites all the
way autumn like i used to say to blake
and kevin love if you guys can't get
announcing jobs after this
you're
brain damaged
what do you mean because they're kevin
loves white and black so it's like if
you guys can't parlay this into [ __ ]
it's funny because all the announcers
are white and all most of the coaches
are white yeah
and all the players are black mm-hmm
and i like explain it
make it make sense i wouldn't change it
for all the teams can i ask you a
basketball question yes
larry bird was he as good as everybody
he was incredible okay he looked like uh
he played like he was drunk and injured
his body moves like he was drunk and
injured why what do you mean he was just
like not cool it was just like sloppy
spinning around
couldn't jump
but
the funny thing about larry bird is how
he was like would talk like there's no
racism like there's it's one of those
things where like
guys couldn't really hate on him why
because he was so [ __ ] good that it's
just like all right yeah like i
like i wanna i wanna say some white boy
[ __ ] but like
you just busted my ass for an hour so i
can't really like even the
my in the in the wait do me a favor look
up larry bird michael jordan last dance
either he calls michael jordan a [ __ ]
or michael jordan calls him a [ __ ] it's
really funny
enjoy yourself dog
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
i'll give you give her money like to
call michael jordan a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
i love the [ __ ] talking yeah
like
uh just something about that like
ah what the guy's [ __ ] weirdly good
it's like luka don john chick now the
greek he's not he's not greek there's
another greek guy but he's like sloven
slovak of some kind he's so good it's
crazy so many slovakia like eastern
european dudes come in they needed the
money
they were tall and they needed the money
honestly
i mean they just it's a good way to get
out it's like the the game took off in
the 80s and 90s and then and those guys
are happening to be 6 10.
and they're but that kid's so good it's
bizarre
it's like history sorry about it because
he's 22
and his his
stats are just
uh he's averaged 20
29
points nine assists
and
i don't have a lot of rebounds
like he's just buried and very young and
very sophisticated just like and guys
can't really [ __ ] with them all right
yeah
it's like it's kind of just like a it's
like an eight mile thing where it's just
like that i was gonna say yes just
reminds me of really good yeah like i
can't if you if you if you physically
not physically in sports physically beat
me but if you're just
what are you gonna do
reminds me of a time um
someone on a black sketch show took one
of my sketches verbatim and tried to
submit it
oh my god i remember my joke about the
last day of slavery
yeah someone transcribed it and
submitted it on a show and another
person knew like you know that's neat
and he was like oh
people are trying to yeah but that well
that's so delicious exactly that will
that only that happens once gang no it
could have happened again but that's
just like a it's like a a weird form of
respect like yeah if i can yeah
um
emails will we do a segment with emails
from what i remember
[Music]
there's a dave chappelle story song
another
day
story from neil
too long but we if you cut it down to
just
just another another bell story
we don't need the thing we don't need
the intro or the outro
um anyhow
oh we got some audios let's do audio
questions
you've got mail hi neil and bianca
i had a sleepover last week
this is relevant because sometime last
year i asked the sleepover girl out
she strung me along for like four months
and then we had a big fight after i made
a joke about tiny boobs that did not go
well
i pulled a nail and doubled down on the
joke because across the period of our
friendship i had said some
worse things and we always just laughed
so i highly believe that she wanted to
say no to me asking her out and was just
looking for a reason pause it
what race do you think this guy is i
believe he's the guy that
that he was the base for the art of
storytelling he was his they based it on
this guy
um he's like
a
caribbean caribbean africa graveyard art
of speculation
uh yeah keep going i have no idea okay
either ways
we are still friends
there may be some residual feelings i
definitely do not want to let the
rejection go because i just want to know
why
do i just ask now
or do i just wait for like seven years
and then ask or do i just let us linger
and not ask at all
also do i just move on
thought out as the top race relationship
podcast so how bianca feel and how healy
thinking i don't know
i don't know what happened wait
um
he's a he's from a for sure from a
french-speaking country
like
i have so many there's he could be from
30 places to me
yeah so i know it's french
martinique yeah you're not that's
possible
can he can we just yeah he'll let us
know just email back your ethnicity
please and nothing else
no video no audio
uh
i like his voice yeah it's good voice
he's a very nice voice
but he doesn't have
he sounds like he lives in the friend
zone
um yeah he doesn't have a he doesn't
have any swag to his voice he didn't
have any girls
no bass no like the [ __ ] no
what does jordan peterson that women
like
uh
no jordan peterson
the the the
teacher the canadian teacher that people
think is controversial
um
he
women like men that are like
kind of testy like i can't hear that guy
talking to me while we're [ __ ] yeah i
mean it's too silly
well i think we'll change positions
good impression
yeah so i
i think
yeah move on i also think that
they're if
i think women i think men do this
somewhat i think women do this more than
men
change the rules
about what's funny based on their mood
and based on like no that's rude but i
did that that was different how
i don't know it was different and you're
just gonna have to eat it yeah yeah eat
it
um move on move on also so funny one of
the options was wait for seven years
well yeah
of course
um
the
the
yeah but i think yeah yeah also you
can't make small boob jokes unless
they're she has huge boobs
if small boob jokes are small boob women
not going to work or not
not going to work if a girl said you had
a small dick you can't get a joke would
you
if i had a small dick and she made it i
wouldn't
that would be our last
that will be our last vacation together
okay
um
that'll be the last time i almost
proposed to her okay um
yeah you can't make a small boot if it's
something that they are probably
insecurity about it you can't
unless you can barely agree with people
if they say something negative about
themselves right you're like what i
didn't see that i didn't notice that do
you have small boobs
that's not yeah goodbye hit it you've
got mail hey neil and bianca glad my
first email made it into the show cops
in california mike ma might make 80 to
100 grand but cops in poorer states make
a lot less i was part of the best paid
agency in the state making 50 grand with
a master's degree there were cops
working way more dangerous cities in
south carolina at the state minimum wage
imagine being able to quit the dangerous
job and go take a job at costco and see
a major race
south carolina minimum wage is 7.50
jesus
um
the uh
it would you know how long it would take
you to buy a house making 750 an hour in
south carolina two months
property value not correct
bianca said something about being
surprised cops listen to the show
liberal cops are like
conservative members of hollywood they
tend to be quiet about their stances on
things just to avoid a deluge of
arguments or problems most of the cops i
know from california to south carolina
love stand-up comedy and listen to every
comedian that you've ever mentioned in
past episodes excluding the cops with
the ego size of texas most cops are like
bianca when dealing with the douche
filming a homeless person
i i gotta say for the record i doubt a
lot of cops are bumping three mics
the sad part i love that little
[ __ ]
thing about his dad
um oh oh and bianca buy a gun
i had the typical california mindset on
guns until i started in law enforcement
your friends talked you out of it and
you had neighbors who did not check on
you or call the police if something
happened those would be the thoughts
that haunt you go get properly trained
in a class and
not buy a friend well i didn't get
talked out of it i got shamed so i don't
want to admit i have a gun i don't have
a gun but if i did i feel like i have to
but if you did where would you keep
i don't have one but i i i just gave it
to my wall
um no i just i feel like if i had one i
would not want to tell people but i
don't like lying about things or not
being forthcoming i'd be like i got a
gun yesterday
no it's not cool in california it's also
a weird thing of like i got a gun it
almost feels like and i'm gonna kill
someone in the next feels like and i'm
gonna use it if you yeah like like what
do you get it's a weird
it's basically like an insurance policy
that you just put in a drawer just like
i don't know
in case they need it
yeah that's going to help me and
something and i feel like a lot of women
who
well also i have a gun
i throw a holiday party up here at my
house i feel like some people will be
like she's a gun
i i think it's easily hot i don't know i
think he's a weirdo would you go over
your friend's house if you knew he had a
lot of guns with that cat would that be
i know a lot of guns or a gun
i i don't know uh yeah i don't think i
would care if he was like taking him out
and [ __ ]
we should use we should go out and
[ __ ] pointing him and [ __ ] i'd be
like dog like no one would do that no no
no no um
but i think about this makes me want to
get a gun too
copycat the copycat i want to be like
you teach me your way bye
hey neil and bianca
big fan of the show here i watch three
mics once a year and i'm a cop no i'm a
kid and i'm amazed that neil can work in
so many different forms of stand up oh
neil did you write this i'm an architect
in detroit but otherwise look like an
effeminate 15 year old white boy for
context
there's my three mike's audience
uh the middle age black dude oh this
middle-aged black dude named greg asked
me to help him design
and build some duplexes wait hold on you
did it wrong i did it wrong
that scared me i was like this is
actually a great question uh sorry big
fan of the show here i i watch three
mics once a year and i'm amazed that
neil can work with so many different for
instance
again that part remains let's reread it
that is great and we love it moral
question about directing and acting for
both of you mel gibson lost a part on
the hangover too because the stars
complained uh of working with him for
his racist rantings yet they had no
problem working with a convicted rapist
named mike tyson again though
if the studio said you had to pick
either directing or acting for bianca
mike tyson or mel gibson who would you
choose
do you go with a violent criminal who
has served as time or an alcoholic
racist to a sober if i had to i'd go
with the racist because i know what to
expect from them i'd be more nervous
around tyson because a person capable of
rape is capable of anything
i'm not excusing gibson but in my mind
violence trumps anything verbal because
it's hate in motion i've been surprised
by how many lady friends of mine picked
mike tyson though is because he's a
child he has a ch he has a children's
cartoon also go easy on sir ben kingsley
he's half indian and was born krishna
banji yeah yeah i got to do those no and
i looked at it because i was like
somebody
he played an iranian in this movie
and i remember in the glass house and
how's the
and
i remember thinking wait maybe he was
indian and then i went and looked back
so i
thinks can apologize my bad
he they darkened
they darkened the [ __ ]
what's funny is
he probably wouldn't have gotten the
part of his name was was christian banji
i don't know you know what i mean like
it's a [ __ ] like in order to play an
indian right you gotta get you gotta
to play an indian he had to become
a sir in england
that's the trailer for ben kingsley um
so what would i rather i this is another
thing i'm thinking about a lot is like
it's just a just a
fake
the
hierarchy and the priorities and like
why this guy trusts mel gibson over mike
tyson
because if you're capable of rape you're
capable of anything okay i don't know
how you came up with that i don't um
and uh
and
i think the only
i could make a case for either of them
i would say um
uh mike tyson because
like per what we were saying earlier i
believe i don't believe you should be
labeled forever i do really i
i am of the mindset of uh rehabilitation
and growth
and you did one thing so who knows what
you know what i mean like it's like okay
but he also has done a lot of self-work
and he's even i watch an interview tyson
tyson yeah a lot yeah and he's even said
you know
if i saw that
you know in the 90s like some joke about
him that's like pejorative he's like i
wouldn't have i would have just went
straight to like i'm gonna kill this guy
when i see him
but when you work on you so i feel like
i've seen
in what little research i've done into
both of them
more
self-work on mike tyson i think that's
why
people [ __ ] with him now in hollywood
too but i don't [ __ ] know i think
yeah i don't in terms of what they're
capable of mel gibson beat his wife like
that seems pretty graphic
so did mike tyson yeah no again but i
don't
i don't see it as like well if you but
the rape you can do anything
somehow
it's the it's the stand-up comedy of
crimes once you do stand up you can
direct you can hang
right
um
i don't i think it has to i think it's
just a matter of
uh fake
ethics on the part of the
actors yeah it's fake it's fake ethics i
mean you could make a case like well
mike did his time
okay
um
i would argue mel gibson
suffered a pretty
uh
severe punishment which i'm not
because he can't really can't really be
in movies he can't be in the studio
he's like in he but he was producing he
was seven years of like not on a poster
not in anything
um
and
i don't know i think that's kind of good
racism in some way but where it's like
the same way we want criminal justice
reform but only for black and brown
people it's like if
uh mike tyson was white
maybe not maybe maybe they're not as
apt as hollywood actors to give the
white guy a chance
um yeah maybe i don't know
enough because i think
what supersedes both of these examples
is
like an r kelly you put out a hit and
it's like okay well was it that big of a
deal you know
like if you if let's see if if let's say
mel gibson produced a huge
tv show that was great
we would just watch i think apocalypto
came out
after well that's what i said he didn't
fully leave like he's right he had to
make it himself but like
he he wasn't invited to other people no
he didn't have a seat at a table anymore
but he wasn't like
i mean it's gotten pretty grim in terms
of stuff that he's been in and i think
he's in something coming
up i don't know
i saw something and i had the thought
uh braveheart too force in nature i
don't [ __ ] know where that is yeah
i'm sure i promise it wasn't very good
um
pray for you agent games panama last
looks dangerous it's just like me yeah i
don't know should a movie called fat man
that's never good
um
yeah it's just gotten sense apocalypto
it's just gotten like who what
is that real
blood father
blood father um
so i don't it's a you could say mike
tyson did his time mel gibson didn't do
his time
i'll say mike tyson seems sad
just as a person
meaning he seems yeah more like he
actually seems like he's done ayahuasca
in a bit more so he has he does he's
done a ton of yeah but he seems very
centered
but he's also cried a lot his daughter
died like there's stuff where it's
he walks around repentant
i don't know how mel got mel gibson
walks around defensive and angry in the
times i've seen him
um but
but i think that it's a double standard
i'm sure because i think if mel gibson
did the time did actual time
i don't know although like i said i
because kevin wasn't allowed to host the
oscars
he can now
be spokesman for a million thing i feel
like people go like well he know he
served his time yeah so i don't i feel
like yeah it
i don't know it's i truly do not know
we're gonna change the podcast i don't
know anything i do not know
i i have a lot of information and i do
not know goodbye hey i wanted to comment
on the show and trial portion of the
podcast just wanted to mention the lady
who said she didn't want to be a snitch
wasn't being a karen
she said she didn't want to be a snitch
because she's a firefighter she was off
duty at the time was trying to reason
force the cops to let her give cpr the
blue wall of silence extends to fire
fighters as well as medics it also
includes not telling a fellow servicemen
what to do even when they are wrong so
she felt like a snitch because she was
violating the unwritten rule of not
telling on others in the profession even
though she ultimately did the right
thing trying to help and testifying she
could still be viewed as a snitch and
get punished by her peers for
uh
while at work i also listened to the
episodes neil did with theo
on this past weekend you two are great
comedic relief together and good and a
good therapy chat neil i think you'll
get married someday to someone you love
so don't give up and don't pretend just
to be
in a relationship but
do know that plant medicine might help
you realize she might be a fat chick
still pretty and amazing just bigger so
don't be too mean about it she could
probably cook you some amazing vegan
food
bianca you always look great on the show
neil's just too hollywood to see it
thank you i see
a mess across from that's my hollywood
training hope you are all having a great
day happy spring and get the vaccine
thank you have a great day he doubled
down on having a great day
that was uh
kind of useful but they don't all have
to be questions some can just be a nice
just mandarin
promoting other podcasts yeah i swear to
god you come on this podcast and you you
write to us talking about other people's
podcasts that's a betrayal
uh no me and theo do have a funny
relationship
uh very different and very similar
very different
the thing i like about theo is he admits
that he's sad
in a way that you wouldn't think because
he's like
from louisiana yeah and he'll admit to
being sad and confused
which [ __ ] makes me laugh
i told theo on one of them that it's
like he's carrying wet laundry with him
all the time
just like i don't know man what goodbye
um
neil and beast here's the detroit guy
you've got mayonnaise i'm an architect
in detroit but otherwise look like an
effeminate 15 year old white boy for
context this middle-aged black dude
named greg asked me to help him design
and build some duplexes on vacant land
he owns in a detroit neighborhood where
he grew up
uh that is bordering
other quickly gentrifying areas on the
surface greg appears to be homeless
when he first came to me i asked him
where he's getting the money to do this
which
uh would approach half a million dollars
he then told me the story of his brother
who got caught up in a gunfight in 2005
was convicted of murder and sent to
prison for 10 years exonerated on a dna
test
and won a civil suit against the city of
detroit for 1.5 million dollars i think
this guy raised a good point about the
amount of black millionaires there are
for for being exonerated i think i think
we don't focus enough we focus
are you changing this we focus
all these ungrateful black millionaires
who were exonerated on dna evidence uh
when he saw that his brother was
spending all the money on strippers and
watches he took control of his account
in order to invest it uh seeing as
seeing it as the only chance to
establish wealth for his family into the
future my question is do i have a moral
obligation to help this dude i have a
lot of reservations about the likelihood
that the project would be successful for
reasons other than greg's complete
ineptitude in developing real estate in
the best case i'd help him establish a
source of passive income for him and his
family in a city and country that has
systematically prevented people like him
from doing so in the worst case i will
waste a year of my life holding his hand
through the entire process and make no
money doing so
a successful new construction rental
property requires a lot of work from a
development and property management
perspective that i'm not sure this
dude's capable of
anyway would love to get your advice on
this and the broader idea of individuals
bearing the moral responsibility for
reparations by sacrificing their own
time and money instead of waiting for
the government to do so very good
question
and speaks to my piece of [ __ ] argument
from earlier
yeah um what do you think
i don't know i mean so
i used to teach
i used to tutor through the like no
child left behind act they had
provisions that was subsidized tutoring
for low-income families and so i would
teach
high school math i owed two to high
school
um
and
the way they did it was t test these
kids when at the beginning of the school
year on things they should know by the
end of the school year see what they
know the least
doesn't make any sense and then teach
them that one subject for a year
that's what everyone thought was a good
idea that sounds like
speaking what sounds like a crackhead
came up with that idea like here's what
we do
all right little man what don't you know
it felt like so many political
politics involved and the result was
just terrible but everyone got a little
bit of their way so i would go to these
families who mostly were undocumented or
low income
and these kids would be it was like two
bedroom with
12 people in it you know
and their
child would be feeling everything and i
only got paid for two hours i paid a lot
of money but it was only for two hours
per kids so
do i sit there and just teach them
for two hours what i'm supposed to
like no you know because i can help them
on all their subjects so i would be
there roughly for four hours each kid
right not getting paid for half the time
or just making half the money i guess
and
making sure that they got their homework
done and i didn't teach any of what i
was supposed to teach because i didn't
think it was effective
just so i could help them get ahead in
their schooling and all my students
became like the class helper for math i
was like very good at that but
i had to sacrifice my time because i was
like i'm gonna i'm you have to be a
piece of [ __ ] to leave these kids
yeah so i i yeah that's my experience
not in the big brothers but but yeah any
one of those things where you go like is
this
you have the ability to help this person
yeah it will be
oh the the it doesn't fully benefit you
just how we place benefit on things time
money
um
but
no clout
uh but it benefits you when you're like
this person will be better off if i help
them
yeah this individual and then you get
into where are they now
where uh i was
[Music]
there you go yeah like how much
like do you ever want to be like hey
what'd you do with it
what'd you do with our time did you
parlay it into
something else something did you just as
soon as i was gone did all your
motivation
did it go back to
to [ __ ] i mean it's and then is that a
waste of your time like is that
it's you know it's impossible to
quantify it's kitchen nightmares
it's kitchen nightmares every time
look up any
they all revert back to where they're
all closed every single restaurant on
kitchen nightmares goes there's like a
very few restaurants that have been on
kitchen nightmares that are open yeah
still
because they take the renovated
restaurant and they just sell it so
working i went to a restaurant or
something
and
you know once some plate a place is bad
for like a decade yes they don't improve
anything no motivation and you just go
oh this is there's no
there's nothing there's no way to fix
this
i can get the thing and that the guy or
woman in charge
does not care exactly and has a bad
aesthetic
they just have a bad aesthetic they
don't know a good chair from a bad chair
they don't understand that they're
lighting sticky tables they just all the
[ __ ] that you would think
like somebody's got to be on this
and they just don't
and and they can survive and they might
make as a business that he walks 60
grand a year yeah [ __ ] it [ __ ] it [ __ ]
it
enjoy i'm not going to support it
anymore we're not going to enjoy but no
but or whatever and whatever whatever
whatever verb you want to put on this
uh but
yet some people are
not even some people everyone is pretty
much what they are yeah
so if this guy
if this person with a lot of experience
in development and you know whatever
housing stuff like that
if he can just see from a mile away like
this guy doesn't
he doesn't know what he's doing
yep right but what does he do
that's right as a good white
i think
this is in 2021 in in this seems like
the first time
it seems like the first time he's gonna
like he's dealt with this yeah you know
he's like [ __ ]
yeah i think just do it do it and i
think do it and then you've done it
you've done it
you can use it as the beginning of a
racist preamble for the next decade well
i tried no it's like the people i taught
in the inner city
racism racism racism you can be like
look i tried to help a black
um
but no try yeah i think you have to try
i would also
as much as you can
explain to them how [ __ ] big of a
pain in the ass it's going to be
even with a property manager being like
you're you can either this can either be
your 24 7 job
or
you're going to get a property manager
and your money's going to get cut in
half yeah and it's still going to be
uh
10 hours of stress a day
yeah you i mean it's up to you you're
going to there's going to be just some
energy lost here so
explain it to him take a night take an
evening
and just you know eat it and explain to
him exactly what is going to go into
this yeah make sure he doesn't leave
being like no that's good yeah yeah sure
like no
listen to me greg
listen to me
this is going to be hard
did i tell you i didn't i i don't think
i've there was a basket a famous
basketball player
that wanted i feel like me to teach them
how to direct oh no okay oh no like nike
ass and i was like location scout
yeah you want to direct
cut get in the [ __ ] passenger van
with me
and we're going to eight locations
in simi valley in studio city how far
did you get eagle rock but he didn't
i never heard back
um but it's like if you want to do it
let's do it so fun yeah if you really
want to do it here's the job this is the
job like it's a pain in that owning
property it's not free it's not just
like passive income it ain't that
passive even with a property manager
yeah even with the property manager and
if you want a a new build the kind of
permits oh zing zoning
okay greg get it but but you owe it's
about preparations
rsc
last week
bianca talked about wanting to purchase
a firearm oh no as a as uh probably one
of the few feelers who owns one i
thought i'd chime in i like how he
assumes
uh earlier in the episode neil said
about mass shootings i was at mendocino
farms the other day i was thinking of
gunman coming in of like what i would do
um this is the exact reason i purchased
a handgun that i concealed carry a few
years ago i was a journalist and was on
scene for one of the worst mass
shootings in recent years while there
was still ongoing gunfire
um
in the weeks after any time i was in a
similar environment i couldn't shake the
feeling that it was going to happen
again but with me as a victim even
though i knew the statistical odds of it
happening were practically zero and
after purchasing one i felt a relative
sense of safety
um
[Music]
uh neil i found it odd about
i found it odd after bianca mentioned
her prior thoughts about purchasing a
firearm your sentiment was but i don't
really have anything worth stealing and
how disassociated it was to your prior
thought of thinking about mass shootings
when you were out and about curious
about
your thinking and banking on what this
might be
uh p.s
neil stream likes joke am i about to
smoke this [ __ ] when someone
cuts you off in whole foods when
carrying a gun is totally a thought i've
had
um sir
turn the gun in
um
uh yeah i mean
i don't want to carry a gun around
i think carrying a gun is
it's so wild to me
carrying a gun i
um
i don't
i don't
this is like some lord of the rings i
don't trust myself with that much power
you know what i mean and i know that's
your joke essentially
but
i just i don't know no what
yeah have you have you ever been in a
situation i've never been in a situation
where i wish i had a gun or a gun would
have
would have helped waving it
but i as a as a cutaway of it on screen
you mean as an off-screen line like how
about now cut to me with the gun
think again um
never
i i remember having this conversation in
a green room at my show
and there's a guy named i believe cindy
castillo comedian said that he was just
in dallas at a gas station
and there was something where he's like
i wish i'd had a gun
dallas
texas is different though right so
i feel like that's a gun that's like
yeah sick shooter yeah uh
so
also a gun at a gas station is not a
good thing
again i think again
um it's me outside the gas station
put the gun down um
yeah so i
i
having been in the desert
a little bit
either thought if i ever owned a house
out there
i would just have a gun in the drop
ceiling or something just like
never
kids
no just in case some wild [ __ ] popped i
don't [ __ ] know yeah like that seems
like the kind of place where
i don't la i don't think i need a gun
even
even though statistically i'm wrong
about crime
yeah i still don't think statistically
you i still don't think statistically i
do either and
i also
i may have been thinking about them at
mendocino farms what were you doing i
might have been getting hungry
yes i was waiting and i was like
it i was waiting for it um and i might
have been hungry um oh god so if neil
gets angry with a gun
um will's dead the
so i still don't need a gun
i only want a gun because episode 103
still don't need a gun i only want a gun
because i live alone and if there was
clearly i can't rely on my neighbors
and i'm
not on the ground floor so i feel like
i don't know
i'm
i'm a goner if i don't have something to
protect myself you know yeah i i mean
that's the it's like people want to have
sex with you huh
people oh let me repeat it people want
to have sex with you
you're like a
trevor noah in a weave
this is my by the one of course it is
okay by the way look up trevor noah's
mom and if it doesn't look like bianca
it does not look like me absolutely it
looks like
someone people have agreed with
me um
young obviously young right there that's
[ __ ] you
the third one in the third one in the
third nope that's the fourth one
that's the second right there it looks
like bianca
that abs that is that
i knows mouth combination is absolutely
um
trevor noah's mother he laid it over a
movie okay okay
trevor anyhow um so i nobody like i said
i have a tv
which is depreciating every day
i don't want to just be one
but like you don't think about that but
there are people who are crazy
so
yeah
bigger comics to kill well what if
they're dead
go kill burr go kill there's plenty of
people
um i just don't would you fight would
you fight
what do you mean like if a guy had a gun
what am i going to fight
you're just going to go out like yeah
yeah yeah
oh yeah [ __ ] no if i sneak up on
them i could do it but if someone has a
gun sneaking up i'm sneaking up but like
a ghoul is sneaking up is so funny uh
i'm still like so if it was just like
you're gonna [ __ ] die like you're not
gonna
no i mean i don't know wow this one's
nails [ __ ] everybody if i have some
opportunity no you know what
rushing a [ __ ] with a gun makes
people do pull the gun trigger you're
just going to keep eating your sweet
green celery offering them chappelle
show dvds
and then slowly but surely i'll tell
them stories yeah i'll call we'll
facetime people you end up you're like
i'm gonna bring you to ayahuasca
hopefully it'll just become a podcast
um
it's like speed but i have to just
entertain the guy
um or he'll keep his heart rate can't
yeah goodbye you've got mayo hey neyland
bianca i'm a long time wednesday lstner
definitely find myself in binky's corner
most often but i love arguing with
neil's bad takes out loud on my commute
i'm a 36 year old woman married for 12
years i have four daughters and i'm
about to be divorced the divorce is
actually going pretty well as opposed to
running any scorched earth campaigns we
both kind of decided to put the weapons
down and sign the [ __ ] treaty i love
it my question is what does dating look
like for a middle-aged divorcee with
basically a billion children
i'm in good shape i'm relatively
attractive and i hold up fairly well in
the intelligent intellect department but
i have no idea what these things are
worth on the open market these days
after being out of the game for so long
i'm generally attracted to men who are
older than myself but for some reason
only younger guys seem to be knocking on
my door
i'm really not looking for any kind of
relationship at this point just trying
to figure out how to catch a respectable
d every now and then that won't fill me
with shame in the morning light wrapping
this here to avoid getting played off by
a long-ass email song so what saying
thanks neil help a dried out old mom get
laid
eternally grateful for your service
first of all she's getting young dudes
you're not that dried out lady well come
on she's like they're offering
themselves i think that
with older dudes
you kind of have to
be like hey
a little bit with older dudes because
more obvious yeah i mean in my
experience i'd be with older dudes i was
always i always waited for women to
sing hold on to me
i'm not like a
i just have to tell you that i've done
that like four times and it's never
worked
[ __ ] can i tell you something
i actually ate a [ __ ] sweet one what
whole foods okay
year was 2014.
i go on my notes app
and i
write the lady a message
and
then say like something something
something
i'm gonna leave i just left it in front
of her and was like
put your number on put your number in
the on the
thing okay if you're interested
n number
no no yeah and i never heard from
yeah
again you act like yeah what's a good
way to do it don't get mad i'm just
saying putting your phone in front of
her i didn't like put it on her face i
like hello
nice to meet you i have something i'd
like you to read i don't know what i
said it was [ __ ] smooth as [ __ ]
really yeah
i don't know that feels a little uh like
pressure swing and a miss did it yeah
it's better i didn't she said it's like
tangible pressure yes i but i didn't
want to waste your time
and i didn't want to be like put my foot
up on the chair be like well
well well what have we here
well well i'm choking
um
i just went for it yeah no yeah it does
not work for me i don't straight up
i need available sexual energy and then
i'll
i will approach yes and i what
i'm i don't mean to make you feel bad
because i do think
that's just the woman in you the women
think that anything that they don't like
no woman would like no i think for the
reasons i said it's
tangible pressure and as a woman
we want to
just if we're not interested we want to
just be we want to be able to slither
away without feeling bad yeah and if
you're like circle yesterday trying to
give me the wrong number
maybe i just mean circle yes or no type
energy is
it was basically give me your number no
it was a smooth way of saying can i have
your number but women also don't like
that
because we feel like fine
yeah i don't want to be what so what am
i supposed to do
what do you women like explain to me how
i could have no no i'm serious i am
going to i'm just saying there's like
burr's joke about telling his wife
okay hit on me you ever hear that joe
it's so [ __ ] funny she's like hey
he's like hey listen
i'm saying i fully am sympathetic to the
fact that
men
you know in these dumb traditional terms
have to hit on women
i
hit on men
for that reason because
i was just having this conversation at
the park with my friend
and she was like there's these guys and
she was like oh my god that guy's so hot
and i was like hey i just screamed hey
yeah and she was like shut um what the
[ __ ]
like
who cares at least we're gonna we either
end up the same way where we are at
right this second or you have his number
and then we all started talking about
just like hitting on guys and she was
saying that
i just i don't i don't want to hit on
guys i want them to come with me i'm
like yeah but guess what guys are also
shy
guys also don't like rejection
they're also winging it so why do
somehow as women we just
shouldn't we don't have to be vulnerable
and put ourselves out there but a guy
should be yeah so i fully
what percentage of women do you think
are doing what you do very few yeah
but what i'm saying but what i'm trying
to tell women is that
guys are very responsive when you hit on
them
you are not a loser you literally you're
not like
it's not like proposing to yourself a
guy it's
it's okay i just think you're more
attuned uh men are more used to getting
rejected yeah so but you know that whole
foods there's nothing to me not knock it
off and i still have
um it was right it was cute it was funny
what are you doing
guys okay
i'd suggest doing it
that's all
you can't take a girl's advice on this
uh you literally can't because you go
girls need to so when is this going to
start
this new policy of women hitting oh i
just do it i put my money with my mouth
of course but i'm not living in your
world
three hours a week and then i it's gone
it's out of my it's out of my house
goodbye and it's about to be out of my
head it's i'm not you have to take the
[ __ ]
i don't
um
you've got neil banks rst and ellie i
love you both and preemptively apologize
for the long-ass email
uh i'm just gonna skim this because this
guy has too many points neil's comment
during sky cop that made a connection
between a women's responsibilities with
their female bodily functions and
potentially heightened morality was very
thought-provoking to me i'd never viewed
personal hygiene in relation to morality
but many random musings in my head
immediately coalesced in support of it
and i wanted to share it in the event
that it helps to develop the theory to
wit
i have always wondered why gypsies
uh oh this is bianca's category oh no i
wonder why gypsies were so hated
throughout roma
throughout i'm sorry were so hated
throughout europe notably being the
ethnic group next in line after jews
that nazis were trying to exterminate i
learned that at least some of the
historic discrimination was based on the
fact that during the black plague gypsy
suffered a significant and
disproportionately
lower mortality rate
than the general population meaning
fewer gypsies died this led to europeans
believe
believing that gypsies possessed some
mystical powers that allowed them to
sidestep the devastation of the pandemic
leading to a distinction as other and
the resulting discrimination and
prejudice against them scholars believe
that scholars believe that higher rate
of survival is actually a result of
their strict hygiene practices
many of which continue to this day one
being the separate washing of clothing
based on whether it is upper or lower
body and more importantly whether the
clothes are worn by men or women clothes
worn by men on their upper body were
washed furthest upstream while clothing
worn by women on their lower body was
washed furthest downstream
by level of filth
only horn that's what we're doing it
only horses and other animals were
washed downstream from women's clothing
i the more i hear about these gypsies
the more i like it
apparently
won't put women's underwear in the
washing machine with men's clothing
clearly menstruation was front and
center and they're concerned of daily
life maybe think of how the most serious
swear words and slurs in jamaican are
both related to the cleaning of the
lower body
uh blood cloth blood clot
and bum cloth bumbaclot did not know
that i'm telling you did you know that
blood clot blood the cotton blood clot
is a bump it's not blood cloth it's butt
blood clot that's what yeah he's put
that's in pre yeah
yes blood clot c-l-l-c-l-a-a-t
no no he's saying it's blood cloth and a
bum cloth whereas it's a blood clot like
a clot not a cloth
from what i understand
you're talking about the
when jamaicans say blood clot what do
they mean a blood clot not a cloth oh
they mean like literally a blood clot
like a blood clot like
like you say like like like mothers were
yelling like you bum like bum bucks
like the johnson johnson vaccine
is what they've been talking about
for years
um
for example stupid uh i found that
interesting a friend of mine uh
every religion has cleaning rituals that
are central components of their practice
christians baptized catholics in holy
water the ritual of wudu ablution
in islam jews have the mitzvah for women
to go in during certain times of the
month i'm sure they're playing anyway it
can't be a coincidence that the world's
major religions that lead billions of
people in their understanding morality
also have these major tenets that relate
to personal hygiene
often specific to women
uh
that's not the end if you can believe it
i mean one of the longest i've ever read
um i think
i guess that's it and it says i think
all of the above relates to your point
somehow but i can't reign it all in
so it's up to us
stitch my crazy thoughts into a
scientific theory you [ __ ]
we don't work for you we work for
[ __ ] better help
radio and talk
no we don't work for you
thank you
all right
but we don't again some good interesting
points interesting look up the blood
cloth blood clot thing
what does bumbaclot mean bumblecloud's
jamaican slang equivalent to douchebag
often used in interjection it's an
insulting bulgarian garrity that refers
that literally refers to either
menstrual pads or toilet paper so bump
cloth yeah bump cloth i'm wrong
bumper clutch yeah and what is uh
blood blood clot
yeah the urban decay says right there
yeah
i'm assuming it's the same i think it's
either or so maybe i'm not
yeah
[Music]
blood
jamaican
so blood cloth blood cloth even if it's
blood clogged they just say it's just
say yeah wrong it's your it's it's uh
bad bobby
play play my songs in the island
the bad robbie
[Music]
that's also uh she's an old caribbean
woman who didn't know what blood clotted
and bumblecloud meant
um
i just didn't know it meant cloth right
yeah i didn't know climbing club that's
yeah yeah
she's an old yeah cut that off because
she wasn't just an old caribbean woman
goodbye
vancouver listener from episode one
shortly after the first time i've ever
heard of neil brennan after seeing you
at the comedy store when visiting la
with some friends quote this skinny
white guy says he wrote for spell show
what one skit or something we'll see
that's the nice credit people give me
when they see me live
we'll see about i don't believe it
guess you weren't lying well i sure
wasn't sir why would i also because you
asked i'm a tuesday listener when i have
enough dishes to do that night otherwise
wednesday then you're not a tuesday
listener sir
it's
tuesday listeners with absolutely no
caveats unqualified tuesday listener is
the new
it's an i'm on an unqualified tuesday
listener anyway neil you mentioned a few
times that actors are basically dumb
good-looking people i don't remember if
you said what separates them from
comedians eg usually writing your own
material having to deliver it in a very
specific way to make it work what else
but what i'm getting at is what about
comedic actors where do they fit into
your spectrum of intelligence i can name
a bunch of people who are hilarious
comedic actors and have never done
stand-up and don't write their own
material but i don't think you'll want
to bash specific people in the winter
circle so i'll leave it to you to give
examples if you want i'll grant you that
choice what does kneel squeal and what's
this bonk's bianca's honks
honestly
this required sign-off competition is
the only reason i've waited this long to
write okay people are scared they're
scared
i mean the people that come to mind are
like uh melissa mccarthy no but what do
you think of them
like paul red's [ __ ] hilarious no do
you think they're just pretty brainless
no because they can improv
and they
can
write they they can rewrite scenes and
you can't teach
it's very hard to teach comedic timing
yeah paul rudd you don't need to teach
like that wasn't something he picked up
from a club paul rudd's been funny since
he was eight yeah paul rudd funny said
some really funny [ __ ] to me after three
mikes
uh
it was a long story
it was something about his son said his
son slammed us his like eight-year-old
son slammed a celebrity who i won't name
and i go uh oh wow he really is your son
because it was like the kind of
celebrity and paul rudd goes uh
yes um
and i really love him unlike your dad
which i don't think dramatic i don't
think uh uh
you know
the [ __ ] anthony hopkins would have
said something that funny
very good
god
yes uh so
yeah they're a lot they're funny
good-looking people who probably have to
write at some point yeah
like natasha leone she do stand-up no
she's [ __ ] hilarious she writes
russian dolls she's involved produced
like just involved and shaping
how to make themselves funny in a way
that's not just like
and then here i'll
do a cross and maybe i should cry hmm
think i should cry can i get enraged
it's just
your goals are different
um and it's kind of almost required at
this point yeah in comedy
like you're not gonna
very few people are just yeah like i
just show up right
what do i say it's not like
the 40s right where even the 40s all
those people shape their material
yeah the marks brothers wrote their [ __ ]
the the jack benny like they all were
like the head writer
um even if they didn't do stand-up so if
you're if you're able to head right
that's what separates you from
dummies
dummies you guys we did our time guys
we filled our time you guys we got you
through another two hours and 25 minutes
a year 27 of your of your life i almost
put a negative
adjective on it positive hold back
your wonderful life
that's it i think cat is here i think i
heard the door open
cat
i know cat said thursday watcher uh-oh
[Music]
it's so good
[Music]
[Music]
goodbye you